foreign
[Applause]
Fitness friend here right at the news
desk you know her from Peloton but did
you know that she eats a piece of
chocolate every night it's the host of
Netflix's dance 100
[Applause]
thank you for having me this is like
dreams do come true oh my gosh
people really love you pun intended like
it's appropriate that your name has the
word love in it because you have a huge
following and you're also so motivating
and you help people and you know we're
going to talk about all of that but
first would you be kind enough to hit
some headlines with us oh of course
afternoon dad so Europe first alley in
Pole Position all right I'm up here we
go
purewell says being a mean girl is so
not fed in 2023 we're hyping up our
friends and I love that think Jamie Lee
Curtis celebrating co-star Michelle yo
here during the award season or t-swift
posting about sza's latest album on
social media we're not competing we are
cheerleading now
thank you
it's true I have to say you are the
ultimate hype woman and I am obsessed
with you for that I mean how do you do
that like how where does that come from
um I don't know I didn't know a I was
it's funny when you're saying that to me
I'm like thinking that's what you do
it's like you literally get people to
like get an exorcism Express themselves
move their bodies sweat live you know I
I think that's what you do
um so you know how do you do it actually
and let me learn from you well I will
say one of the things that comes to mind
is energy is contagious right and I
think my job in life sincerely not as a
Peloton structure not as the CEO and
founder of Love squad or the interena
host of the Brooklyn Nets or Netflix
host is sincerely to walk in any space
and be present and bring good energy and
it doesn't mean I'm faking it right
there are days we have that aren't good
we get some terrible news but I don't
make my problems other people's problems
right I'm honest and how I feel so if
I'm not feeling it I'll show up in a
space and I'm like okay I don't feel
great today but I'm present and I feel
like being honest in a space allows me
to Champion other people around me I can
give you that energy I'm so glad that
you answered that question because I
just learned something thank you Ally
thank you all right up next from the
guardian it's bare minimum Mondays
there's a new viral Trend where you
basically do as little as possible on
Mondays and it's to ease yourself back
into that work week and according to
tick tock this helps fight off the thing
which I seriously suffer from the Sunday
scaries boy are they real you have those
on Sunday really do why because you're
like taking stock of the week everything
you have to do coming up I I just know
like um you know because of work and
kids like so we have work schedules and
school schedules that we're all
experiencing the Sunday scaries and it's
game time and I don't dislike Mondays I
actually think if you've been festering
all weekend Monday is a great you know
day to get off the thought process and
get into the doing it process because
people get a little you know not so
thrilled when you start bothering them
about work on a Saturday or Sunday but
Monday it's like fair game go time
so Monday's no problem Sundays I do I
get really anxious and I feel like the
fun and relaxation and whatever I've
decompressed from just shoots right back
up into my stress levels I think this
makes me a little nervous if you do the
minimum Monday then you're going to do
take it easy Tuesday
we'll see Wednesday
totally slippery slippery slope do you
attack Mondays you seem like someone who
does that I attack the fact that you
feel bad about Monday so like I just
talked about being positive and all
these things but in all honesty I feed
off Sunday scaries yeah because I know
everyone's nervous about Monday so I'm
like let's go like I look at Monday and
I'm like bring it on you know what I
mean I knew you would I do get like
Wednesday night scaries no one else I'm
like sweating on Wednesday nights I'm
like Thursday and Friday another two
where you know I get a little nervous no
Wednesday scaries no just me no no okay
raise your hand if Sunday freaks you out
really okay raise your hand if Monday
freaks you out more yeah
way less what are y'all doing
interesting Sunday I'm still like a
happy hour girl I'm like I'm still on
the weekend let's go Mondays when it
gets real you're like oh man I was gonna
say because in Sunday fun days is a real
thing oh it is a real thing yeah I'll
see you next Sunday everyone I'll be
there
okay all right the Wall Street Journal
reports when one teens cheer squad quit
days before the big Championship she did
not stay home no she picked up her
pom-poms and she went to that
Championship alone Katrina Cowell is the
first solo cheerleader to compete in
Nebraska state championship history and
when she was done her competitors they
rushed in with hugs of encouragement
because honey if you even if you have
just one problem
[Applause]
you better
you better it is everything advocate for
your advocate for your friends be your
own cheerleader just don't let life or
the world or your circumstances stop you
thank you for jumping mid-air and being
my inspiration
dance 100 looking for the next great
choreographer I mean do you think you
found one yet we have they are
exceptional
I won't let the cat out of the bag
because I want you to watch the show but
I will say as I'm hosting the show you
saw that picture of Katrina when she's
mid-air that's how I hosted midair in a
shadow baby I'm host NDS 100 on Netflix
like that but no we have found the next
best choreographer and they've won a
hundred thousand dollars the show airs
on March 17th six episodes the drama the
talent I mean the professionalism of the
dancers dancers are often put in the
back right we're behind the scenes as a
former dancer you get you're the most
underpaid underrated athletes and most
times like think of Rihanna halftime
show love the dancers they were
exceptional exceptional do you know any
of them by face by name no no and in
this show you will know them by face you
will know them by name you will know
what they say they are not only our
dance 100 the dancers they are judge and
jury they decide which choreographer
wins a hundred thousand dollars
trust me that is what me and my girls
will be watching and we might even save
it for Sunday when we need it the most
up next we like ice because he makes his
fourth appearance on our show he is one
of our original favorite guests and he's
he talks about finding love in Las Vegas
I want to hear about this
foreign
[Music]